아, 진짜 다 공실이네. 진짜 어떻게
이렇게 됐지? 이게 제 매뉴 올
때마다 이렇게 계속 더 안 좋아지는게
눈에 보여 가지고 좀 진짜 안타까긴
하네요. 경기 침체와 높은 임대료가
문제였는데 예. 과연 예전 명성을
되찾을 수 있을지 네. 그래서 지금
가로숙길에 왔는데 시간이 좀 이르는
시간이긴 하지만 정말 사람이
없습니다. 진짜 요쪽길에 저기 끝까지
딱 두 분 계시는 거 같아요. 올
때마다 느끼는 거지만 정말 계속 좀
상황이 좋지 않은 거 같습니다. 어,
그래서 가로스길 공실율이 작년 4분기
기준으로 41% 정도라고 해요. 근데
실제로 와서 보면 그거보다 더 높아
보입니다. 뭐 반 이상이 비어 있고
실제로 와서 체감하면 한 거의 6,
70% 이상 그 이상 비어 있는 거
같아요. 공실률이 너무 심하고 유동
인구도 많이 줄었습니다. 그래서
강남구 공실율이 한 15% 정도
되거든요. 그거와 비교해서 거의 두
배 이상 높은 공실을 보이고 있는데
그리고 지금 뒤에 보이는 건물을 제가
좀 소개해 드릴 건데 최근에 매각된
사례입니다. 그래서이 건물이
2016년도에 325억에 매각이
됐어요. 그래서 되게 유명한 회사
회장님한테 매각이 되는데 이게 최근에
300억에 매각이 됐습니다. 거의 한
9년이 지난 다음에도 불구하고 원가
이하로 매각한 사례예요. 되게 잘
매입한 거 같아요. 그래서
300억이면 뭐 돼지 평단가로 한
2억 초반대 정도인데 2억 초반 대면
여기 이제 그 15m 대로변 코너에
이쪽 이면도 다 평당히 2억에
팔리거든요. 세로 스킬. 근데 지금
가로 스킬 대로변에 2억 초반에
매각된 사례이다 보니까 제가 봤을
때는 좀 뭐 지금 상황이 좋지 않지만
그래도 굉장히 좀 잘 매입한 그런
사례라고 좀 보여집니다. 원래 전에
그 H&M이 있었어요. 그 임차인이
나가고 되게 장기간 공식 상태로
유지되고 있습니다. 그래서 이게
나중에 임대가 어떻게 찰지도 좀
보시면 좋을 거 같아요. 차는
임차인이 없네요. 네. 그래서 그
정도로 다 비어 있을 정도로 지금
상황이 좀 좋지 않은 거
[음악]
같습니다. 강호동시가 2018년도에
141억 원에 매입을 했습니다.
최근에 166억에 매각을 했는데 거의
6년 동안 취득세 감안하면 시세
차액이 거의 없어요. 네. 그 정도로
거의 원가 수준에 매각한 건물이라고
보시면 될 거 같습니다. 그리고 원래
임차인이 통으로 있었다가 나간지 꽤
오래됐거든요. 그래서 정말 몇 년
동안 공실 상태로 납두다가 최근에
매각을 했습니다. 그리고 매입한
사람이 MC몽이라고 해 가지고 최근에
좀 기사가 많이 나갔는데 MC몽 씨가
엔터테인먼트 회사를 설립을 했거든요.
그래서 원헌드레드라고 엔터테인먼트
사업을 하고 있는데 아마 사업으로 좀
직접 사용하지 않을까 그렇게 생각을
하고 있습니다. 그리고 여러분들 또
아셔야 될게 지금 가로스길이 국내
최초로 일조건 사선을 완화해 준
곳이에요. 네. 그래서 지금 여러분들
건물 보시다 보면 3층 이상부터
1조권 사선 받은 건물들이 많거든요.
그래서 그것 때문에 건물 모양도 좀
이상하고 건축 면적도 애매하게 나오는
경우가 많은데 그거를 완화해 준다라고
합니다. 그러면 정말 5층까지
반듯하게 지울 수 있어요. 네.
그러면 건물 활용도도 되게 높아지고
임차 업종들도 괜찮은 업종들을 마칠
수가
있습니다. 거의 다 비어 있고 들어와
있는게 거의 애플 스토어밖에 없는
정도인 거 같아요. 그래서 저게 워낙
장기 계약을 해 가지고 지금 아직까지
좀 들어와 있긴 하는데 지금 쓸쓸하게
애플 스토어만 들어와 있는 거
같습니다. 그래서 나머지는 진짜 여기
다 비어 있어요. 저는 진짜 좀
참담한게 상권이 정말 죽었다라고
느끼는 지표 중에 하나가 저런
깔세거든요. 네. 그래서 저렇게
임대가 너무 안 되다 보니까 저렇게
단기 임대를 마치려고 저렇게 깔세를
붙여 놨는데 그만큼 많이 침체가
됐다라고 보시면 될 거 같습니다.
아, 진짜
엄청 심각합니다. 지금 뭐 차 있는
데가 없어요. 여기 와 보세요. 여기
비어 있지? 저기 비어 있지. 저기
비어 있지. 여기 비어 있지. 저쪽에
비어 있지.
네. 그래서 여러분들이 건물 다들
아실 것 같은데 가로 스킬 딱 초입에
있는 첫 번째 건물입니다. 그래서
리모델링을 한 다음에 진짜 몇 년
동안 공실이에요. 그래서 지금
아직까지도 공실인데 이게 지금 전층
임대료가 월세가 1억 2천 정도
됩니다. 보증금 20억에 1억 2천에
임대가 나와 있는데 평당 임대가로
봤을 때 임대 면적 기준으로는 65만
원 그다음에 전용 면적 기준으로는
거의 80만 원 됩니다. 그래서 그
정도로 임대료 수준이 되게 높아요.
그래서 저희가 일전에 강남역도
말씀드렸는데 거기 못지 않게 지금
높은 임대료에 마치고 있는데 아직까지
임대가 되지 않고 있습니다. 그래서
제가 진짜 예컨데 거의 리모델링 한지
거의 한 2, 3년 넘은 거 같은데
그래서 그 정도 넘을 정도로 계속
비어져 있는 상태인 거 같습니다.
이거를 보듯이 가로스길에서 가장
초입해 있고 도산대로도 같이 끼고
있는 정말 위치가 좋은데도 불구하고
이렇게 오랫동안 공실 상태로 유지돼
있는 걸 보면은 정말 상권이 오랜
시간 동안 좀 회복되지 않았구나라고
좀 느낄 수 있는 거 같습니다. 근데
가로 스길이 지금 이렇게 상권이 안
좋은데도 불구하고 여기 바로 이면에
세로 스킬은 그래도 유동인 거 더
많습니다. 테로 스킬로 한번 좀
이동해서 임대가 어떻게 차 있고
임대료 수준이 어떤지 한번 직접 가서
보도록 하겠습니다.
[음악]
가시죠. 네. 그래서 여기가 세로
스길이에요, 여러분. 도로가 상권이
확장되기 딱 좋은 도로입니다.
가로스킬 쪽이 임대료가 워낙 높기
때문에 거의 반가격이라고 보시면 될
거 같아요. 상대적으로 임차인들이
여기이면 쪽을 좀 더 많이 선호하는
거 같습니다. 가로스끼리 좀 살려면
임대료를 조금 조정할 필요가 있어요.
그래서 예전에 악구정 로데오도 죽었을
때 건물주분들이 다 임대료를 좀
인하했거든요. 가로스길도 제가 봤을
때 좀 사려면 임대료 조정이랑 건물주
전체적으로 임차인들이 잘 들어올 수
있게끔 환경을 마련해 주는게 좋은 거
[음악]
같습니다. 가로스킬 리면의 나로 스킬
쪽에 와 있는데 원래 여기가 상권이
되게 좋았었거든요. 거의 새로 습기
못지 않게 인차인들도 되게 많고
좋아하는데 유동 인공어도 많고 근데
여기 상황은 확실히 새로 스킬보다는
상황이 더 안 좋은 거 같습니다.
제가 있는 곳이 예전에 제가
2016년도에 중계한 건물이에요.
그래서 그때 당시에는 다가구
주택이었는데 그거를 멸실한 다음에
이렇게 건물을 올렸습니다. 그리고
지금요 건물 위에층 3부층을 보면은
아무래도 일조건 사선을 받아 가지고
건물이 꺾여 있어요. 네. 꺾여 있어
가지고 좀 활용도가 되게 낫습니다.
아까 말씀드렸던 것처럼 사선 완화를
하면 좀 반듯한 건물들이 더 많아질
것으로 좀 예상이 돼서 그래서 저는
개인적으로 일조건 사선이 좀
폐지됐으면 좋겠습니다. 살려 줄 때는
확실히 좀 살려두고 그래서 오늘 좀
총평을 하자면 가로 스킬 공실이 진짜
심각합니다. 제가 봤을 때 거의 한
7, 80% 이상 다 비어 있는 거
같아요. 성임대로 진행하는 것들,
건물들 보면 대부분 다 막 50만 원
이상 뭐 진짜 7, 80만 원짜리도
되게 많아요. 아직까지도 임대료를
높게 책정해 가지고 지금 임대를
진행하고 있습니다. 임대를 낮게
맞치면은 건물 가격의 타격이 크기
때문에 일부러 안 맞고 좀 있는 거
같아요. 제가 봤을 때 가로스끼리
살려면 예전에 악구정 로데오가 그랬던
것처럼 건물끼리 다 단압을 해서
임대료를 조금 낮추든지 임차인들이 좀
편하게 와서 장사할 수 있게끔 환경을
만들어 주는게 되게 중요한 거
같습니다. 뭔가 컨텐츠를 입혀야지
진짜 성수나 한남으로 갔었던 그런
젊은 사람들이 찾아올 수 있다라고 좀
생각을 하거든요.이 가로스킬만의
컨텐츠를 좀 만들어 가지고 다시
사람들이 좀 올 수 있게 하는게
중요한 거 같습니다. 그래서 여러분들
가로스킬 상권이 어떻게 다시 살아나고
어떻게 발전할지 여러분들 계속
지켜보시면 좋을 거 같고 제가
빌사남이 간다 계속 이렇게 현장 가서
좀 취재를 하고 있는데 여러분들이
만약에 궁금해하시거나 뭐 이런 상건은
좀 찍어 줬으면 좋겠다라는 상건
있으면 댓글 남겨 주시면 제가 직접
가서 촬영해 보도록 하겠습니다.
그래서 오늘 영상 여기까지 하고요.
여러분들 빌딩은 역시 빌사함.
[음악]